sous la pluie plus de huit heures avant
même l'arrivée de donald trump la foule
est au rendez vous à la veille de la
primaire démocrate
les fidèles veulent montrer qu'ils sont
là en force et que peu importe le
candidat qui affrontera le président en
novembre
il n'aura aucune chance en 2016 trump a
perdu par seulement 2700 vote face à
clinton
cette fois ci les républicains mettent
le paquet pour remporter le nuage scheer
mais pas tous et l'ancienne présidente
du parti républicain de l'état atteinte
elle n'a pas voté pour trump en 2016 et
elle ne votera pas pour lui cette fois
ci n'ont hélas fondé de link comme
project qui rassemble des républicains
qui veulent tout faire pour qu'il ne
soit pas réélu
quitte à voter dans l'espoir d'y tels
que ce ne soit pas à bernis en deux
le socialiste qui soit choisi par le
parti bob gainey lui a voté pour
troubles il ya quatre ans il ne le
regrette pas mais cette fois ci il est à
des six vétérans de l'armée il estime
que le président ne mérite pas d'être
reporté au pouvoir
sa collègue qui a servi dans les rangs
de la force aérienne en irak est du même
avis n'a pas y même s'il a fait bouger
les choses à washington elle n'a
aujourd'hui qu'une formule à la bouche
tout sauf trump en 2020 elle se
considère maintenant comme indépendante
et son choix se porte sur tout le sig
aborde une démocrate ancienne
combattante et qualifié par certains de
libertarienne est plus à droite
sinon mais à moins d'un improbable coup
théâtre gabarn n'a aucune chance de
remporter l'investiture et aimer bieber
insiders passé de 3,1 passes enders
serait devenue sa dernière option
quant à jennifer horne elle est partagée
entre voter pour pitbull adjedj où amy
klobuchar difficile d'évaluer le poids
de ces indécis et de ces républicains
déçu et de l'impact de leur choix final
façade rome
en tout cas si une image vaut mille mots
pour l'instant ces foules donne
l'impression que leur bataille est loin
d'être gagnée
l'amérique est plus que jamais un champ
de bataille entre les pros trump et les
anti tron et l'issue est encore
incertaine
pour l'instant ici frédéric arnould
radio-canada à manchester au new
hampshire
[Musique]